we've all dreamed of world peace at one
time or another cynics might say that
total uninterrupted peace on a global
scale is something that could never be
achieved wars crime unstable political
relationships international tension as
long as human beings have the capacity
for these things they will remain as
obstacles standing in the way of world
peace and then there's all the scps and
dangerous anomalies out there just the
existence of half of the horrors
contained by the scp foundation could
easily bring about the end of the entire
world as we know it and it's hard to
achieve peace when death and destruction
could be right around the corner but
what if that wasn't the case what if
there was no end of the world scenario
no evil eldritch god pulling the strings
above and no catastrophe waiting to
finally drop what if the world was just
safe if an existence of perfect peace
and harmony still sounds like a pipe
dream to you then perhaps you should
join us on a trip into the unknown a
journey into a world where things are so
much better than here welcome to
scp-6001
to avalon a safer and more peaceful
world has always been at least partially
the goal of the scp foundation and it is
true that without their containment and
understanding of anomalous objects the
world would be a far more dangerous
place if it wasn't completely destroyed
in its entirety however there is always
more that the foundation could do with
their vast resources to improve the
world there are even scps that they have
contained whose anomalous abilities
could greatly benefit all of mankind but
the organization would hardly ever
approve of doing anything like that
right well scp-6001 is a universe in
which that actually happened or rather
something similar happened here the
resources of an organization like the
foundation were put to better use and
ultimately created a utopia a paradise
for all achieving what we referred to at
the start of this video world peace the
entry for scp-6001 on the scp archive
opens with an email addressed to us from
a member of foundation personnel called
david caspian that reads hey sorry i
know it's late but i just had to share
this with someone there is no one in the
world i'd rather share it with than you
i just had the most incredible day then
as the article continues there are
numerous format changes from the
standard scp foundation entries that
we're familiar with in particular the
type of terminology is vastly altered
from what we'd be familiar with the term
scp is now phenom special containment
procedures have been replaced with modis
imprimus takes the place of description
and even the name of the organization is
different the compendium phenomic
inquiry this appears to be a version of
the scp foundation that exists in some
kind of parallel universe or alternate
timeline to the foundation that we know
phenom 6001 itself is a tiny microscopic
singularity uncovered in the tokyo of
this other universe's japan this
singularity is linked to another version
of tokyo from another universe which is
referred to as a6k this universe a6k is
described by the compendium as being
similar to their own reality in almost
every superficial and surface level way
it looks the same contains the same
people the same places and even the same
anomalies but that is where the
similarities end the a6k universe
diverges from this baseline by having a
general lack of cooperation among its
inhabitants scientific repression along
with heightened paranoia aggression and
levels of violence sound familiar it
should because a6k's main scientific
institution is a group known as the scp
foundation
that's right a6k is the foundation's
reality the foundation is aware of what
it refers to as scp-6001
but because of the tiny size of the
singularity that links their world with
that of the compendium none of their
personnel are able to travel through to
that reality the compendium states that
it is considering unifying with the
foundation striking up an alliance
between universes however they both have
dramatically different approaches which
would likely get in the way of that the
scp foundation has always been shrouded
in secrecy never revealing anything to
the public often eliminating or memory
wiping anyone who witnesses an anomaly
just to keep everything under wraps
meanwhile in their universe the cpi has
willingly made its documents and
anomalous information available to
anyone that asks for it in the
foundation's reality the world they were
linked to via scp-6001 was seemingly
first discovered when david caspian the
personnel member we mentioned earlier
hunched over the spot where the
singularity was located for almost five
minutes he had been doing this for a
number of weeks since the foundation's
instruments first detected the existence
of the tiny hole connecting a6k with
another dimension david's focus had been
so fixated on that spot where
scp-6001 was that it wasn't until he got
back up that he realized he was in a
completely different universe he
described tall rounded skyscrapers
unlike the tokyo of the foundation's
world gigantic ivy growing up the
buildings with leaves the size of cars
the clouds above had been replaced with
the clearest blue sky and clean fresh
air took the place of the stale polluted
environment david had just left a nearby
cat was perched on the same rooftop as
david watching strange seed-shaped glass
constructs floating on the horizon
filled with lush green innards the cat
had a coat of spotted orange white and
browned underneath an actual coat a
violet blazer complete with a white bow
under the collar and a black brooch
pinned to it the shape of an eye inside
a globe it even wore a pair of
spectacles the cat primrose greeted
david by name and introduced herself the
pair sharing a brief joke about stepping
through the looking glass both of them
were doctors in fact david was the
foundation's head of alt-dimensional
research when he asked pimrose how he'd
arrived on her side of scp-6001
she responded by asking if he had heard
of something called cross-dimensional
test sampling of course david was more
than familiar with it not only was it a
standard procedure for the scp
foundation but one that he himself had
written the procedure involved bringing
an isolated part of another reality to a
safe environment within one's own for
testing purposes this is exactly what
the compendium had done to bring david
to their universe according to primrose
the compendium had many similar
procedures to the foundation causing
david to ask why if this was the case he
wasn't being scanned or checked for
contaminants and pathogens or paralyzed
to prevent kinatographic mimetics
primrose responded by simply asking if
he had eaten breakfast and seemingly
inviting him to paris primrose then sat
with david on an armchair on the tokyo
rooftop and spoke an address to it the
next moment she and david were
transported to paris in a courtyard
filled with similar chairs that other
people and animals were using to
teleport primrose referred to them as
the everywhere chair a form of public
transport david remarked that there was
something similar in the a6k universe
referring to scp-1609
which was destroyed by the global occult
coalition the cat responded by saying
that david would find many similarities
between their universes and mentioned
that she was the department head of
trans-dimensional development and
discovery for the cpi but then primrose
declared she no longer wanted to discuss
work as she was already off the clock
despite it only being the early hours of
the morning when david questioned this
primrose replied the wonders of
automation david more hands make less
work and we have a lot of hands besides
i have something more important lined up
for today she then ordered uh royier
from a holographic menu and david
ordered the same remarking when in rome
or paris or a parallel reality with
talking cats he'd do as the romans david
then asked primrose about the compendium
learning that it was the primary
scientific institute but it lacked the
employees of the scp foundation primrose
and her fellow researchers were under no
obligation to work for the cpi but
rather were able to choose to work with
them out of their own curiosity or
interest the compendium was also
responsible for running the governments
economies and law enforcement of the
entire world with primrose likening the
organization to benevolent dictators
david then expressed surprise that
people didn't resist the compendium
taking control of the world to which his
feline counterpart replied goodness no
governments certainly corporations
absolutely the people though imagine a
foreign power suddenly swooping in and
saying hey there so we're in charge now
here's universal healthcare living wages
housing infrastructure and total liberty
from anyone but us and literally all we
ask you is to respect basic human rights
that's it we provide the rest tax-free
this also includes ethically replicated
barbecue instant global transport and
adorable talking animals also the cure
to cancer can you really think of anyone
so wedded to the existing power
structures that they just say no to all
that it is easy to see why people would
so willingly accept something so
universally beneficial by the time the
compendium had gone public they already
had been working with world governments
in the shadows much like the scp
foundation at first the public response
had been rough but all it took was a few
years of human life on earth improving
to help the naysayers change their tune
partway through their meal david and
primrose discussed the compendium
further she revealed that something
called pact 15 was currently in the
process of being rolled out worldwide
pact stood for phenom application and or
combination technology phenoms being the
cpi term for an scp or anomaly the
initiative had come about after the
compendium studied an australian talking
spider or
scp-1470 as david knew it the goal of
pax was to find a use for phenoms that
would not only be beneficial to the
people of their universe but would also
benefit the phenoms themselves these
creatures objects or entities were all
given the freedom to choose whether or
not they complied and those that did
would find their existence to be bliss
david was given a tour of primrose's
world encountering all manner of
familiar scps that had been repurposed
and allowed to live their best possible
lives alongside human beings living in
uninterrupted peace for example dr kleff
seemingly pulled off the impossible by
finally curing 682 of its aggression
shortly after finding a whole nest of
the creatures 682 species dubbed the
emortagons have since both proliferated
and really mellowed out with the og-682
stating that it no longer finds humans
disgusting another nightmarish anomaly
from david's universe
scp-173 the sculpture has found a new
lease on life in this world too it lives
in a museum adored by everyone who sees
it and it uses a mere second of being
unseen every night to reshape itself
into a new beautiful construction turns
out a lot of its aggression merely came
from being confined as a piece of art it
wanted to be looked at and loved not
locked away and feared meanwhile however
the various groups that formed the
compendium phenomic inquiry were casting
their votes on what would be done about
the residents of dimension a6k
what would they do about the foundation
some among the compendium saw the people
of their neighboring universe as
prisoners needing liberation groups
known as the wanderers and the charity
hoped to save universe a6k to heal a
world in need of their help after all
this universe had a means to cure
diseases and famines and ultimately
achieve total peace and wanted to share
their gifts with the foundation's world
however one by one opposing votes were
cast other groups like the synthetic
assembly looked to how a6k treated
machines like slaves refusing them of
their own free agency
another known as the partnership of
three argued that a6k held no value
their natural resources deplete at a
staggering rate the labor force is
sickly and untrained their cultural
dissimilarities are
well laughable we have everything they
have and what little uniqueness they
bring to market so to speak isn't worth
its counter space they wouldn't even
make a good tourist trap but kind of
morbid sob would want to visit these
wonders of theirs it's all tombs and
constructs of war or crumbling
architecture where people would fight
each other to the death for spot and who
defaces a perfectly good mountain like
that with a bunch of dead people's faces
some of the compendium claimed that the
people of universe a6k had to learn to
overcome their own adversities rather
than the easy option for their
universe's people to come in to fix
everything others simply claimed that
a6k was just irredeemable it's people
not to be trusted finally the vote was
settled the compendium would deny help
to the foundation and its universe and
would seal
scp-6001 just enough to keep them out
but they would watch over a 6k and the
day when the people of that universe
were ready to come and ask for the
compendium's help the day they were
ready to finally know world peace they
would be welcomed with open arms
needless to say that day hasn't arrived
yet we just really
really hope it does sometime soon one
person however did get a happy ending in
this story none other than david himself
who now works blissfully in a bar in
alternate osaka we'd love to be happy
for him but frankly we're a little too
jealous now go check out scp-001 when
day breaks and scp-001 oroboro cycle the
full story compilation for more
alternate universe craziness